hi I'm Ryan Beck and welcome to IKEA
furniture prescription-drug or tie
politician I'm gonna say a word and
you're gonna let me know
is it a ikea furniture a prescription
drug or thai politician only I know and
they're not going to get it right Matt
how do you even play this are you ready
to start we're ready wonderful I've been
prepared for this my whole life
are you ready to play look because I
feel like you're showing me your card I
didn't I'm gonna shovel it yeah your
first word is your coffee your coffee
that coffee at the end yeah very like
table Lee oh that's IKEA it's a
prescription drug my friend that's just
to do prescription drugs is indicated
for treatment of patients with
intermediate or high-risk
Milot fibrosis oh milla fibrosis of
course what's that Google it sounds like
something I usually walk on walk in on
my boyfriend doing ah they just got it
uh-huh who's there dudes next word
Tarver sounds like it could be like a
bookshelf now this is the one that
sounds the most like IKEA furniture but
I feel like I keep getting burnt with
these prescription medications I thought
that was part of a vagina
that's a vulva that's a bull easily
confused
sarva Prime Minister of Thailand what
I'm worried that this game is making me
seem racially insensitive to South Asian
people you're not the only one mm-hmm I
think I've shattered at Arve that's an
Ikea furniture that's correct
I know for a fact is IKEA furniture
because I owned one you own this wall
lamp yes retails in 1999 so make sure to
watch a special 1999 something that
everyone who works here can afford when
you make money and you can afford it
then you should shop it up here because
it's a real trip
I'm truly only sitting like this because
I want my shoe in the shot
what , what Tana Matata forever is a
phrase that just came to mind I'm gonna
say politician you got it politician
Wattana forever I love that guy voted
for him Minister of Social Development
and human security I'm
human insecurities did you know that
Thai Panther again insensitive people
have been complaining that this game is
maybe like culturally insensitive yeah
well you know these they got a straight
white hos what a stupid game yeah cuz
you lost some would say it's an expertly
crafted game
thanks for playing that was IKEA
furniture prescription drug or Thai
politician yeah thanks for having me I
was forced
[Music]
you